how you feeling good good will you fix
my head
is it brushed uh i don't want it brushed
i want more of a natural just pull it
back
should we try the andrew bloom or what's
his name orlando bloom thing or no
no no last night was
off the charts um
we um we started snuggling
and we started to kiss and she is so
beautiful and soft and caring
she's a giver did you guys have sex
okay so yeah i mean we
we made love all night
that was great last night by the way
mm-hmm but both times
we did it about twice and liz's body
is amazing it's like a surreal dream
it's just like i it was incredible like
incredible
i never had anyone take over and make
love to me
in my life it will go down in big ed
history as
yeah as the event so now
i'm just hoping that every time it's
gonna be like that i mean
i wanted bun we do my bun it is a bun oh
it is
oh wow okay um how much more time you
need
um just a little bit but on lashes
finish my lipstick
how was the rest of your night this is
really good
yeah it was a good night is he a good
kisser had to teach him how to kiss
so i feel like i have to train him to do
a lot of things
but we laughed about it
you